un nuevo ataque a otra planta nuclear
ucraniana volodymyr selenski compartió
vía telegram imágenes de una explosión a
tan sólo 300 metros de los reactores de
la planta piden o crimes según el
presidente de ucrania el bombardeo fue
perpetrado por las tropas rusas y dañó
los edificios de la central los
invasores querían disparar nuevamente
pero olvidaron lo que es una planta de
energía nuclear rusia pone en peligro al
mundo entero tenemos que detener esto
antes de que sea demasiado tarde
la planta más grande de europa ubicada
en sap orilla fue cerrada a principios
de este mes debido a bombardeos cercanos
a la zona ataques que ucrania y rusia se
adjudicaron mutuamente entretanto otros
señalamientos llegan a rusia por parte
de ucrania este domingo fueron exhumados
más cuerpos de las 440 tumbas de la fosa
común que se les que reportó a las
afueras de la ciudad de siún el
presidente de ucrania dijo que había
evidencias de tortura y comparó la
situación con lo sucedido en busca en
abril cuando se encontraron fosas
comunes en la periferia de la capital
kiev y pidió que el hecho sea marcado
como crimen de guerra por parte de la
comunidad internacional y aunque aún no
se han establecido las causas de las
muertes este lunes se conoció la primera
reacción oficial rusa a las acusaciones
ucranianas el kremlin calificó los
señalamientos de mentira y aseguró que
se encargara de contar la verdadera
historia
es el mismo guión que empuja todo se
desarrolla por el mismo guión es una
mentira la misión de derechos humanos
que la onu tiene desplegada en ucrania
anunció que tenía previsto verificar los
hallazgos sobre el terreno y la
presidencia de la unión europea pidió
establecer un tribunal especial para
juzgar los supuestos crímenes